we did it we did it we pulled it off
didn't we we pulled it off we we broke
the deadlock we ended the gridlock we
smashed the roadblock and in this
glorious glorious pre-breakfast moment
before a new dawn rises on a new day and
a new government I want first of all to
pay tribute to good colleagues who lost
their seats through no fault of their
own in the in the elections just gone by
and I of course want to congratulate
absolutely everybody involved in
securing the biggest conservative
majority since I like you ladies as I
look around look Shirley's before many
of you aboard and with this mandate and
this majority we will at last be able to
do what paying attention because this
this election means that getting brexit
done is now the irrefutable irresistible
unarguable decision of the British
people and with this election I think we
put an end to all those middle miserable
threats of a second referendum I say I
say respectfully
I say respectfully to her to our
stentorian friend in the blue 12 star
hat that's it time to put a sock in the
megaphone everybody's in peace my
message to all those who voted for us
yesterday especially those who voted for
us conservatives one nation
conservatives for the first time you may
only have lent us your vote you may not
think of yourself as a natural Tory and
as I I think I said eleven years ago to
the people of London when I was elected
in what was thought of as a neighbor
city your hand may have quivered over
the ballot paper as before you put your
cross in the conservative box and you
may intend to return to labour next time
run and if that is the case I am humbled
that you have put your trust in me and
that you have put your trust in us and I
we will never take your support for
granted
and I will make it and we I will make it
my mission to work night and day flat
out to prove you right in voting for me
this time and to earn your support in
the future and I say to you that in this
election your voice has been heard and
about time too because we politicians
have squandered the last three years
three and a half years in squabbles
about braixen we've even been arguing
about arguing and about the tone of our
arguments and I will put an end to all
that nonsense and we will get brexit
done on time by the 31st of January no
ifs no buts no maybes leaving the
European Union as one United Kingdom
taking back control of our laws borders
money our trade immigration system
delivering on the Democratic mandate of
the people and at the same time this one
nation Conservative government will
massively increase our investment in the
NHS the health service that represents
the very best of our country with this
single beautiful idea that whoever we
are rich poor young old the NHS is there
for us when we are sick and every day
that service performs miracles and that
is why the NHS is this one nation
Conservative government's top priority
and so we will deliver 50,000 more
nurses and fifty million more GP surgery
appointments and how many new hospitals
and we will deliver long term NHS budget
enshrined in law 650 million extra every
week health secretary and all the other
and all the other priorities that you
the people of this country voted for
record spending on schools an Australian
style points based immigration system
more police oni colossal new investments
in infrastructure in science using our
incredible technological advice
Edge's to make this country the cleanest
greenest on earth with the most
far-reaching environmental program and
you the people of this country voted to
be carbon neutral in this election you
voted to be carbon neutral by 2050 and
will do it you also ready to recall be
neutral by by Christmas by the way you
voted for all these things and it is now
this government this People's Government
it's our solemn duty to deliver on each
and every one of those commitments and
it is a great and heavy responsibility a
sacred trust for me for every newly
elected Conservative MP for everyone in
this room and everyone in this party and
I repeat that in winning this election
we have won votes and the trust of
people who have never voted conservative
before and people who have always voted
for other parties those people won't
change
we cannot must not must not let them
down and in delivering change we must
change too we must recognize the
incredible reality that we now speak as
a one nation Conservative Party
literally for everyone from working -
working - from Kensington I'm proud to
say to clear itself from Surrey Heath to
Sedgefield from Wimbledon to
Wolverhampton and as the nation hands us
this historic mandate we must rise to
the challenge and to the level of
expectations and Parliament must change
so that we in Parliament are working for
you the British people and that is what
we will now do isn't it that is what we
will do let's let's go let's go out and
get on with it
unite this country let's spread
opportunity to every corner of the UK
with superb education superbeing
infrastructure and technology let's get
brexit done but first my friends let's
get breakfast done
[Applause]